this is a production of cornell
university
so welcome to a very
obvious
auditorium here to talk about i think an
interesting topic
how well we do how well will we do in
the 21st century it all depends on us
essentially
as i said like just to kind of pick
layer to start with
as you can see my name
matis
some people they think it sounds like
malthus
and i just would like to declare from
the get-go i have an anti-malfunction
say are you an optimist or are you a
pessimist
and obviously i say i'm an engineer
and like an engineer gets asked
here we design a bridge is the bridge
strong enough then the engineer makes
calculations
and says
i think the bridge needs two more beams
be strong enough
and very very seldom is the engineer
asked
are your optimists or a pessimist why
are you so pessimistic
he says i'm gonna test it out i just say
two more beans yeah whatever
and that's what i say just two more
planets that's it
is this pragmatist
engineers right from or get strong from
understanding basic principles or in
financially the fundamentals well the
fundamental thriving in the situation if
you understand first principles better
you can make much better decisions
that's
the bottom line
okay
and the fundamentals change somehow in
real life it's more complex than a
little machine an engineer design
so there are many many principles at
work and you have to decide which ones
are the priority principles because you
cannot
give attention to 500
and i think the argument i would like to
make is that the top five are shifting
there's a new principle
being added to head of the top five
probably and understanding that will
help you make better decisions
so it's all about opportunity in the end
and also how the opportunity is that's
why i
gave you a little
uh
tool to say tomorrow normally you go to
events and you have to
the first version was sponsored by swiss
government so that this neat little
swiss cross
here which made it very legitimate
at the airport
and yeah so the joke is following
it's not the spatula
it's not a good way of killing it but
anyway so
she says you know
swiss cheese
no she says swiss pocket knives
can cut pretty well through swiss cheese
but this pocket knife
cuts through the water
so the idea is a little bit actually
with sustainability people say oh it's
so complicated it's so complex i would
say it's not complicated or complex it's
just different it's quite simple
you know
do we use more than what we have
kind of last
you know that
something new
so what i would like to to do is this
time i have the opportunity to talk
twice
about
cornell this one is more focused on just
what about the economic implications and
why would i focus on that it's a bit of
a sour sad realization myself in my own
life i'm from switzerland and so we try
to engage with nations and we got
switzerland to the point where where the
where the statistical office is
downloading our data after having done
some review with us and this is that is
of the results more or less robust and
our publishing
the results of the swiss footprint is
three times more than switzerland has
within its own boundaries
and
it also mirrors
article 73 of the swiss constitution
which says we swish and the cantons of
switzerland strive towards living within
the means of nature
that's beautiful
swiss constitution is just intentions
i grew up
the generation after world war iii my
parents lived in world war ii
switzerland had seven months of food per
year
uh in world war ii it was surrounded by
war and fascist forces very difficult
oh my god what can we do russian food
and you know
grow potatoes in the garden didn't
really help that much but kind of
boosted the morale
build
a merchant
fleet
during world war ii of the swiss flag
having no access to the ocean i mean so
desperate
they took various action
um
not very interesting fact so that's why
we kind of shifted our attention
slightly shifted not by abandoning our
past our past has been how can we
document resource constraints
so how can we put numbers around that in
terms of how much
and now we kind of extend that a bit to
say actually to what extent what's the
evidence that resource constraints
what's the evidence that resource
constraints have a material and
substantive impact
that we will see action what's the now
that seems quite obvious in some ways
and it's kind of surprising to me that
there's very little
evidence that me that really strange
seems so crucial
so i would like to show you some ways
how we're starting to think about that
topic and it's far from conclusive
but uh so so i'm really here kind of
looking for help really
we can't do it and here's a little
brainstorm so i i bank on it
so how do we do that
our our
and can you hear me in the back is it
okay okay
otherwise you just come closer
and
we just have two messages
as global football network an
organization 30 people and only two
messages that makes 15 people per
message
and we have two offices that makes one
message per office one in in in oakland
one in geneva now
and the message is
the first one is
the short form
by capacity is king
and the longer one is to say by capacity
will be the limiting fact of the 21st
century
so if you look at resource constraints
because there are lots of resources how
is it best to think about it i would say
really that
life happens on the surface
life competes for these surfaces
life does quite well without mercury
so yes mercury or other
rare earth may be limiting in some ways
but that's a question of energy both to
get it out of the ground and to make
sure it doesn't pollute so so energy is
a way to kind of deal with industrial
metabolism
but ultimately it's the
life force that is limiting
now we can kind of fool ourselves with
fossil fuel always hard to say
so many similar words because it can
allow us to do more than what
biocapacity can regenerate and you start
to recognize there's not enough capacity
to deal with the waste
so the waste is more limiting than the
source for fossil fuel as well so by
capacity limiting we may have the wisdom
to move out of fossil fuels because
we're already way beyond 350 ppm
so we actually took that seriously
this is fuel some years ago but we
haven't had the whistle yet
that would make put more pressure on the
rest of the biosphere because somehow we
want to get energy perhaps
biological energy biomass
or we don't have the wisdom we burn
everything we've already found and we
many estimates would suggest that the
ppn concentration in the atmosphere
would go above
to put everything you found so far
and that's that's when indoor air
specialists would say we should start to
ventilate the room people get drowsy now
you can't ventilate that easily if
outsiders send me another ppm but anyhow
so so it's a significant amount and that
means two things one is five capacity
probably will be on the more threat i
mean there will be maybe there might be
some winners but overall most likely
bypass will go down
and
trust international trust would probably
be seriously compromised in such a
situation because why are you wrecking
the plan right in the planet so
international trust is a precondition
for a global economy international trade
so you may be less able to get access to
buy the plastic melt here
maybe
so in either scenario by capacity's king
that's how he's at by capacity's king
why king because we like fairy tales
even though switzerland since 1291
hasn't had a king where i'm from uh you
still like kings
so bypass is king it's the first message
maybe i don't know if it would work on a
t-shirt it's not that sexy but i mean
this is the dna
second with the second question and the
second message the second message is
actually
then
if you look at you
some of you have already opened it and
you did read the warning did you
did you read the warning
yes uh
um
it's
this map which is a bit poorly printed
didn't get the callers right here the
idea is um
if you look at the word like a farmer if
you look at the word for a biocapacity
perspective
it suddenly shapes very differently you
can see that some countries
some countries have far more capacity
than what they use for their
consumptions they are really true farms
others are more like hobby farms
with two chickens you know
one tomato plant in the kitchen window
and then perhaps a rabbit
and yeah so
it doesn't get you very far probably
farming it's nice but you should have to
go and work somewhere else to buy food
from somewhere else but if everybody
else has a hobby farm where do you get
the stuff from
that's kind of the question so what that
the second says
essentially is to say
in a world of reasonable constraints
looking at the word recognizing by
capacity
the national self-interest in
aggressively addressing the biocapacity
constraints and reducing your bypass
deficit
that self-interest is overwhelming i'm
not talking about in life and
self-interest i'm talking about dog eats
dog
that's kind of can't trust
self interest is overwhelming now what
is stunning to me and i'm looking for an
ass and i have no clue
is why could there be such a big policy
failure
why do nations unanimously around the
world that their entire cabinets and
ministerial
support not recognize
self-interest questions i mean some do a
little bit more like china is thinking a
bit more ahead i had a friend of mine
who
didn't exchange scholarships
in the mid 80s early 80s
and he got the only heated room among
all the chinese students and there were
also some african students in vagina
uh they got medium well treatment not so
well not so well as european it's kind
of funny how that works out i thought
everybody was equal but it didn't seem
that way anyhow he got he was quite
happy to have some heating out he was
cold and um
i asked him so these chinese food what
do they study oh engineering
oh so i'm sure they offer this course in
french and english so they can kind of
make progress fast because chinese want
for international solidarity to help
their
fellow people around the world
get technical skills and no no they have
to learn chinese first
and so wow that's more complicated
engineering i started engineering but i
could never study in chinese i mean so
conflicts how come
because the chinese they were thinking
ahead now they have colonies in africa
where they can
like speak chinese
so so they have four sides they're one
of the few large countries that have
foresight enough foresight i don't know
in terms of just are they able to outrun
the resource constraints but some other
countries large countries that have
formed that institutional foresight
within government
i don't want to name them they have
great academic institutions great
knowledge but somehow there's a
translated
administrative foresight
anyhow
so that's the two messages
bicaps is king
the self-interest is overwhelming and
i'm
totally surprised when it's not gotten
but the good news really is
the potential energy you know that's an
engineering idea no potential
we just don't know yet how to explore it
but there's a lot of potential energy
you just need catalystic
energy and then you can make it happen
so i'm not proposing citizens work do
you notice
it's not a bad thing please do the right
thing
you will never win
but you'll feel good when you die yeah
that's not that's not the point to say
okay actually it's a winnable race
but it needs a bit of catalytic energy
it's a minimal catalyst
so
how do we make the economic argument
we start
with what we always had before
uh we map
countries
demand for resources against how much do
they have available in their country and
we do that like farmers we say how much
area is there in the country high
productive is it per hectare that gives
us the buy capacity
so it's kind of a how much share of the
global productivity is in your country
that's one part and the other one is to
say okay how much
area is needed to regenerate the flows
you depend on both for
providing resources for accommodating
the space that you pave over for your
beautiful roads and buildings and
the capacity that you need to absorb
waste that
competes i mean if the waste is absorbed
like a cow that poops on the on the
pasture the absorptive
functions are overlaid with productive
ones and so it's not a new area but if
you have the industrial mode you produce
core in one place you ship it to holland
they clean pigs and then they'll destroy
the water and they're like
they use two areas for the same thing in
competition to kind of provide the
services
now
the main
waste flow if we calculate in our
international calculations because of
lack of data co2 is kind of an emission
from fossil fuel uh
the question is how much buy capacity
would you
need or do you need because some of it
is observed to absorb this flow
so these are kind of all competing uses
of
nature
so as i said
we do everything per capita not
everything
but per capita is kind of interesting
because people look through their own
eyes that's how they experience the
world
so per capita what you see typically in
that take italy as an example italy had
a slight decrease in body capacity
because they're more people to a large
extent
and their demand of footprint went up
quite substantially particularly since
they entered the eu
so they used about one and a half
italy's in 1961 that's when united
nations started to
track
data quite consistently country by
country 1961 today they use about
i think four or five until they can't
remember exactly
something like that i think between four
or five features they use
what's the problem have you been to
italy
it's quite nice there's a prime tourist
destination people think there's great
food and local food and slow food and
wonderful
what's the problem
that's exactly the point there's no
problem
apparently they think oh they have a bit
of a
so
when you look at this and switzerland
looks a bit flatter so switzerland looks
like this
they increase a little bit and they're
kind of stabilized sort of
comparatively and switzerland also has a
higher gdp so kind of relatively
speaking
what's the problem so that's why i was
looking to translate it into economic
language
and just to say quality
what does it cost
what does it cost to run this bypass
deficit
and the answer is nothing
that's kind of interesting italy can buy
for each of it it doesn't even cost them
anything so they do something that is
physically not replicable worldwide and
don't get a signal back to say wow
there's something kind of that doesn't
add up
so in the past if you look at resource
cost trends
you saw the resource costs overall they
were kind of more going down the sloping
overall probably know the famous bet
between simon and
julian simon paul earlier
there was a bit of a blip in the 70s for
the oil prices
and and now since the year 2000 though
the prices are going up again
why would they go up forever i don't
know
so because prices
are
okay i know
prices
people say scarcity makes rises go up
you hope that's a
it's a deep belief
and uh
what people mean by scarcity are
different things it's true like in on a
market if it gets scarce typically then
the price goes up
but if scarcity in the world like the
resource is bigger that doesn't
necessarily translate into market price
like if you measure the voltage
at the plot here
it doesn't tell you if there's enough
coal
forever to keep the voltage up so
there's two different concepts you have
how much stuff is there to replenish the
market is the market and if the market
gets used yes the price reacts
so there's a much more painless
relationship between here
and the the stock
so still i mean eventually you may see
prices go up they're actually very
interesting studies that i looked at did
the prize predict the extinction of the
knee extinction of the buffaloes or the
beaver
and it didn't
till the last one that rises back again
oh my god
where the buffalo
so
in the best cases prices go up then you
can react in the worst cases prices
don't go up and then you start left to
eruption you know so
prices going up is a good thing because
it gives you information about the
future and if you are not well enough
okay
now prices are going up
what is also interesting that's what
jonathan
grant and pointed out for the first time
prices in the
recent history prices of resources go up
during a recession
never happened before
there you have the price go up so now if
you multiply prices by amount of by
capacity deficit what do you see for
interlink okay
their cost was relatively minor to the
gdp it's but now it's multiplying
prices go up and the deficit goes up to
multiply
you're going up
bigger and bigger so if there's a small
part of the gdp
it's becoming steep enough that you can
say the downward escalator is going
faster and faster and they're not able
to run up anymore that easily
so it comes to it starts to compete with
the sides
of of growth
so they cannot so
so basically it makes it more difficult
with the resource constraints becoming a
cost that draws in there
now
what we were quite shocked to see but
it's a very rough analysis of costs if
you look at some former soviet republics
like uzbekistan or kazakhstan that have
quite low gdp
or the notion
if you calculate
their energy consumption
at world market prices
that cost is higher than the gdp
can imagine
their energy consumption at work market
price is more than that
that's stunning how can you say
resources are manufactured
it's more than everything
that's just the energy
so uh so it's kind of surprising to me
what i said energy
resources are not yet seen as a major
driver
so that's one thing i'm saying wow
yes in the past
it wasn't the main major factor and as a
factor was actually declining and
important so
yeah maybe it may have been reasonable
reasonable enough to think about it
but it's hard in the future to make that
argument particularly because it's not
easy to move out of in the local deficit
because that's given by your population
size doesn't change that quickly it's
given by the way your infrastructure is
built doesn't change that quickly so
overall
you know so you're kind of stuck and
also word market prices you cannot
manipulate that easily so overall
it makes it difficult
now another way of looking at it is to
say okay
that's the cost
but it may be not so significant so
perhaps we were able to have impedance
it's another way of asking the question
to say
does italy
have the financial capacity to bid for
all these resources how is their ability
developing to bid for these resources
and that also brings to a shift of the
past
and the future
the past
was about
i would call the factory work the
simplified with and then if you have a
better way of framing it or
naming it let me know
i call it the factory word because in
the past
you earn more money
you want more cars you buy more cars the
factory produces more cars the more cars
you buy the more cars are being built
so all that matters is absolutely income
it's a factory rate
now we're moving into new words
and i would call it the global auction
why global auction we are one happy
global community of one global economy
we are all drawing on the same resources
the service of the planet hasn't been
expanding very rapidly
okay we can produce a little bit more
per hectare but not that significant
anymore overall i mean for our high
priority an average has increased about
20 percent agriculture being a big boost
but overall you know productivity is not
moving that much so
demand is increasing much so we all are
looking at the same reasons more
countries
run ecological deficits and they want
stuff from the rest of the world
so what's the consequence
we are all bidding they're all sitting
in the same planet we've altered in the
same room
for the same picassos are they're not
being painted anymore
we can't live without these picassos
because they are the cherries and the
tomatoes and the things we want you know
lowest highest failure yeah
but it's a bidding process
what makes it more likely that you what
makes it more like that you succeed in
bidding
of course we're having
steel nerves
i would say in simple terms it's your
relative income
doesn't matter how much you have it
matters also how much to all the others
have
so what you need to know is not
how much your talents earn but what is
the average italian slice of the overall
earning power
and how is that developing over time
if your slice your relative slice is
getting smaller does it make it more
likely
to get the same amount
of the resources
actually depends what more and more
so so if
you just look at that trend
you see is kind of something like this
actually you have to translate about the
70s by the 40
loss
for the italian in terms of their share
to its worth
faster
so
tell the story again
italy
wants more and more from the world
not only that
they want more and more of the world and
it gets more and more expensive per unit
not only that
their ability to purchase
relative to others gets less and less
what do you call that
so
that's a big economic argument
how can we say you know that there's
there's no link between economic
performance and social
uh
how can you say the link between
economics
and resources
so let me show you kind of these graphs
again a little bit and then we can have
a conversation
so
we start again from just saying
we're living in a new world
if you look at the world like a farmer
the self-interest is becoming obvious
um
i apologize i know some people have a
hard time seeing green and red so the
red countries are kind of the
all the ones horizontal from the united
states europe north africa india china
japan
the population belt the tempered belt
with far larger demands than what what
they have when i was born
and that was just kind of
not so long ago
in 1962 i was born the world looked very
different
so so we are in a new ballgame now it's
a new it's a new context
so here italy
i think it's about five-fold it's about
now down to one hectare by capacity per
capita
uh the graph you show that twitter
talents they say so what so it just was
to say so what
at this point
so how did we measure that
again just to repeat it's basically it's
actually this is a graphic that the new
zealand government produced and they
kind of like it because you can't really
argue with it okay we use surfaces you
may be arguing why why did they use
arnold schwarzenegger as a model but
otherwise i mean there are many people
obsessed with arnold schwarzenegger
apart from that yeah we need surface and
it's competing for space
this is a world bank
pink sheet
the world bank looks at commodity prices
over time have you seen this this graph
yeah
you can download the data from from the
world bank
you see the peak in the 70s of the
prices you know so it's kind of this
declining commodity prices and this
increase more recently
so you multiply that with the buy
capacity deficit then you get a sense of
where we're heading
now it may not continue forever like
that i don't know i'm just saying
if it doesn't then we are even more
believers of this disruption because
this is that's i mean that's a strange
thing i said it already you know
hla not realizing that they are in a
physically difficult position because
the price doesn't tell them anything
in the past
here the graph of italy's of the
italians share in world income
so
they use more and the blue line shows
they have less and less
obviously also the share
per capita worldwide is always less
because more and more people
that exacerbates but basically
the bid it doesn't only matter
you know if you want if
you it matters how many are out there
and how much do they have so
if per capita everybody has still the
same but double as many people
competing with you makes it more
difficult
here just
four different countries
looking at to what extent is the share
of the american the italian the chinese
of world income these are not my
inventions really i mean the the point
is only we just downloaded the
information from the world bank on gdp
it's not like something cooked up
it's just a question how should you look
at the world you know so if you look at
the graph
if you live if you continue to live in
the factory world and say that's the
word
then you just look at this graph
oh gdp is rising what's the problem
that's good
nucleus
only ones though to look at from
the auction where they say wow what what
do we have to look at and that's really
the question any pilot or any air
aeronautic engineer ask themselves
before they build an airplane and say of
the dashboard what does the pilot need
to know to safely operate the plane
that's that's the question and so you
need to understand what context is the
plane in you know if you if you if you
fly the fog you have to look at
different types of dials than if you fly
kind of or you're just trying to land or
yeah so it depends on
what the problem is
we see china's share of the world income
is rising very rapidly
um
so it may may grow even more rapidly
than their the growth of their buyer
capacity deficit i'm not sure
but still since their purchasing power
or their bidding power is far less than
world average it still means like they
are yeah it's growing so that on the
trend side but it's at the low level so
that also makes it more difficult to buy
so it helps as a trend it's probably
better to kind of have more and more
relative to others and
uh in absolute it also matters
but as a strategy like for italy to say
okay well the actually you really should
do if you want to stay on this growth
trajectory of having more and more by
capacity deficit you need to out-compete
everybody else in the world forever
it's a great strategy that works just
for the one
at the top of the pyramid
it's not a replicable strategy so if you
think you can outsmart the rest of the
world forever
be my guest and that's the good strategy
for you
there's some who thinks that but it's
not a very stable stat anyhow
so let's look at
some european examples here
uh for
all you internet people there's gonna be
extensions are kind of the countries
we see a number of things one is i think
one of the big misconceptions is that we
all sit in one boat of resource
constraints and so why should i care
because we are on the same boat
we're not in the same boat
we are all countries are very distinct
patterns
it matters how you relate to these
resource constraints or how to you will
navigate the future
uh and um
you see italy again that i showed before
the middle smack in the middle
and it's kind of similar to
four other countries and patterns
four countries here have quite rapidly
expanded their res their buy capacity
deficit over the last few years
and these numbers only go to 2005. we
have some newer numbers but just you
don't even have to look at the newer
numbers and surprise surprise
surprise surprise what also are they
known for these countries
economic collapse i mean
so if you expand your demand
and don't have the purchasing power to
kind of maintain it
it's just dangerous
so we're just now engaged in a project
with the finance industry that's why i
have to go tomorrow to
washington for a conference
um just to look at that and say because
currently credit rating is blind to
resource constraints
that seems silly really
so let me perhaps to summarize and then
we can have a conversation more uh
here's some countries in the
mediterranean region and the red ones
like
china world united states and then the
average mid all the other ones are
mediterranean countries
if you look at them and say okay how has
the gdp increased
and how does that how has their buy
capacity deficit increase so that by
capacity deficit for most has increased
quite dramatically in the mediterranean
and they also have increased their gdp
so lomborg would say
great
the more deficit you produce the richer
you get what's the problem
it seems to be a good recipe what's what
are you worried about
um
and you can see like the ice stage
rather flatter so as large increase from
a factory perspective if you say okay
what matters is my income i can buy more
or you look at it from a perspective of
the global auction world
this is not about correlation or
anything you just say there's actually a
double whammy countries run more and
more by capacity deficit
well for most
they also
run
a smaller and smaller sliver
of uh of bio capacity of
sliver of the higher capacity no smaller
smaller sliver of global income
no so that's the other what's the
average chinese sliver of global income
what's the average
american's sliver of global income
over the last i think it's a loss since
1970 i don't know exactly anymore which
year it
starts
i think this is cyprus we're not sure if
the if the data is strange enough
the long the long arrow which
is cypress oh they have a little bit
more sliver overall
but much much larger by capacity deficit
are they better off now than they were
before
i don't know
so what's the practical implication
we call it slow things first it's a very
simple idea
if you track
our demand the red curve compared to
number of planets
in the past we went to from about one
and a half from about half a planet but
i was born to about one and a half
planets now roughly so it depends a bit
on how exactly calculated but roughly
and if you look at
how will it be in the future we don't
know
but we just translate
moderate united nations projections
moderate not the aggressive one moderate
ones say what do we think will happen
does the united nations say and they say
okay we'll move towards using two
planets very quickly
is that physically possible i'm not sure
i'm not confident it is but that's our
wishful thinking almost moderate wishful
thinking
so then the question becomes for
investment when you put stock in place
today
what kind of investments should you do
which ones will become traps which ones
will become opportunities
those investments that depend on cheap
resources to operate them
will lose in value if resources get hard
to get by
it's pretty straightforward it could
distinguish
so we can choose do we want to build
ourselves do you want to lock yourself
in with your friends or with your
enemies
yeah
because infrastructure decisions lock us
in that's just
where they are
so again
so we have choice
uh last thing i want to say to show is
kind of
but we can leave that for discussion
actually i won't show it that much but
you can
i won't go to that just let's have
discussion
let me summarize here
i think two two points
i would like to make one is
the planet has a budget
how much do you have how much do you use
you know it's kind of useful to know
like
president clinton said in his
presidential campaign it's by capacity
stupid in the end that's 21st century
um
and if we don't recognize it the
blindness already now does cost lives
and we miss enormous opportunities
that's kind of the bottom line i think
so
what i want to say is fundamental
understanding fundamentals helps you
make better decisions there are huge
opportunities out there that it could
seize
why did you see them
so simple
so with that
that's the
conversation i would also like to
circulate something else
those interested in staying
communication we have a newsletter
uh of
uh that where we kind of report on kind
of new things if you're interested in it
you can put your email on this yellow
sheet
and uh
see how we fail in the future
and just put that in the back
and now it's open for questions and
there's already a question excellent
yes
if you are in an auction
okay
i understood what he asked is if i could
explain better why is it relative
income and not absolute income that
matters in an auction
if we all depend on something essential
that we cannot be without like a picasso
cannot be without
there's a limited amount
you you want to get a certain slice of
it you know
so
if others have a lot of purchasing power
you cannot bid them out very easily so
it depends not only how much money you
have it's not a fixed price it depends
on how much money all the other people
have to bid for it
so we know a certain point in time how
much the italians could get
you know from that global bidding
and then the next year
let's assume the earth is generous
there's still as much available but
people want more
and at the same time relatively to the
others you have a smaller sliver
compared to everybody else in the room
does that indicate it will make it
easier or more difficult or difficult to
get your
amount of resources
so that's why
it's not just the absolute it is kind of
everybody wants
that will determine how much you can
secure for getting your by capacity
deficit so having a bicapacity deficit
in the world in overshoot you put
yourself at
the risk exposure
of
if you cannot out compete the rest
economically
you cannot grow more rapidly your
economy than the rest
then it's difficult and that's my point
is not to be pro or anti-growth or
anything i'm just saying
in a resource-constrained world growth
may come to a halt
and then
it makes it even more difficult to kind
of operate so
does that
address a question
yes so we have
three questions so we start here and
then we move on should we start from
my left to the right so again
as you mentioned that uh switzerland is
taking no action on this
um yeah um
approaches and i think you can't take
full credit for that for example there's
an initiative called 2000 watt society
where they say now we use about 6 000
watts per person the united states about
10 000 watts 12 000 watts per person we
need to move to that one
and it's still mainly driven by more
which is surprising if it's not seen as
much as potatoes
i had the most interesting conversations
i think in two countries one is the
united nations who are supporting us as
well
they have a much more elaborate
relationship with wealth generally than
most other countries so they found oil
out of the ground they recognize it's
not income it's a transfer of assets
until they put the money in jamaica
and they have seen so much change in the
last 40 years that they're not afraid of
change they know there will be different
futures they know there will be a
postcard for future and so it's not a
booth they may not act accordingly fast
enough but i mean
they're buying up a lot of
sustainability experts
they're heading the bedding they're
edging their beds pets
another interesting country is ecuador
has been very innovative beyond cochrane
as well and has recognized
to some extent within the planning
industry
that
moving out of an ecological
it hasn't been as strong
but if it's true that
there's such a strong self-interest of
nations why our nation's not
jumping to it
it's a framing question i mean
i mean i would say to the europeans
they're so awfully stupid that they went
to copenhagen
that they said
we will reduce co2 emissions 20
and if other people participate we'll
reduce it
they should say nobody participates
we'll go much further because there's so
much
at risk we cannot afford we take it
seriously we do it no matter what but to
make it conditional on others
you have to be a good boy good boy
okay
this
um
um
or how should one think about
strategies for the future because those
countries
everything that
is attractive now the tourism side we
have been able to distinguish that so
well so if a mexican comes to spain and
drinks a lot of fear
it wouldn't be counted as mexican for
example the kind of spanish consumption
so that's a distortion in our capital i
know there are huge flows of tourists
coming but they don't stay for the whole
year so the numbers of tourists who
can't do that
but i mean it's a bit of a distortion
a little bit in terms of strategies what
should we do i mean i think i mean
it's not any different from if if you go
to the camp and we can't even allow you
spending two times more than what you
earn what you need to do you very
quickly know what it means
it's pretty straightforward in some ways
but i think first we need to want to
change and and i think that's
what anything about it so they don't
really
think that it's significant it's a
deficit that they don't think has a
cause or a consequence
that's i think that that needs to be
understood first at a top level as one
of the primary drivers of preparedness
but we could we could build prosperity
we could have powerful lives
uh
that's like half a person per country
or something
so so that's why we focus our strategy
our key audience are 2 000 people in the
world
that's what we want to focus on we have
started too
slowly
and these 2 000 people are economic
advisers of ministers
career
administrators
he said
you can't make people change
you have to present them in opportunity
the collaboration that they say okay
we make
they see the possibility of having
conversation with peers making their
lives go easier and more effective and
succeed more sleep better at night
so i mean the way we approach it through
conversations helping them to kind of
feel more effectively with their
problems
i mean going back accordingly
or making friends
okay
sloppy way sorry
so there so there are two superimposed
graphs one just shows
the past consumption one the future
projection which i think is not feasible
but that's our hope
in such a world you say can your
investment live in such a world most
real assets that we put in place today
have very long life spans
so if you put them in place they
basically will determine our consumption
patterns for decades to come
and
if there's something that require a lot
of resources to operate they will lose
in value so the net present value of
investments that are depending on cheap
resources
which probably will drop dramatically if
you look at it from that perspective
is that does that
yeah
okay one more question and that will be
the end okay
yeah so this is crap
i'm not in control of the human
development index and it was revised and
they so we just use the official way
they they they put it and uh
i i'm not as happy with the new
definition that compared to the old one
that's another discussion
so now we just said what the
what they define as high development
is kind of 0.67 on the scale of the hdi
i know
i know
it's kind of it's they say the rat race
must go on
but anyhow so i mean we're just saying
okay if they say that's what we should
we should get to
do we have the resources to do it and i
think that that's something that the
untp is starting to struggle with in
some ways they say oh my god all the
development success we've seen in the
past depends on more resources
but now we don't have more resources how
would it end up
and they don't know what to do about
that
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu